if you've registered to vote by post
your postal vote will be delivered over
the coming weeks
inside you'll find your buck ballot
paper your postal voting statement two
envelopes clearly marked a and B and an
instruction sheet first separate your
postal voting statement from any
attached items next complete your ballot
paper in black ink on the reverse for
your ballot paper you will see your
ballot number place your completed
ballot paper into the envelope labeled
envelope a with your ballot paper number
clearly visible through the envelopes
window and seal the envelope next
complete your postal voting statement in
black ink this is the sheet that has the
date of the election and your ward at
the top your postal voting statement has
a return address addressed to the
returning officer on the back place your
voting statement together with envelope
a into envelope B with the return
address visible through the window of
the envelope seal envelope B now you're
all done you don't need a stamp and can
post the envelope at any post office or
postal box voting by post is easy the
deadline to apply for a postal vote is
Monday the 15th of April you can find
the postal vote application form online
on the gov you K website